put your hands together daddy get it I
get it why do you bring these little
dinky girls around
it hasn't know how I am with women as
soon as I have sex with men and excite
all of my interests magically dissipated
it's time to grow up doesn't it get old
no it stays right around 20 what it's
not whack my little brother your heart
is frozen because of your emotional
immaturity not that shallow
watch out said bull I'm an agent I get a
piece of all the action please my
advisors say that I can't engage in any
negative facial expressions so Karen
does that for me now you understand
where I'm sitting will you sign me up
doll I make sure your swag is right
anyway got worried about nothing look
you've been dreaming about being with
ginger since we were kids
are not in one of these little floozies
to my wedding you've been dreaming about
having a little Ricky's running around
you're not pregnant yet it's those
Brazilian briefs you've been wearing
have you seen the population in Brazil
and I've been dreaming about making
money driving a fast car and hooking up
with models don't be friends with him
cuz he's the best hole we ever met in my
life
take us on a bet you date a woman till
Vic's wedding and see if you get
attached so you've never been in a
long-term relationship no yeah I've
never been in a short relationship I
want to try something new the sex is
amazing she's cool I remember how you
felt at the ends in an O do not really
that every moment come on guys
damn chick she got you good this girl is
amazing what she walks in the room it's
special you have the capacity to love
and that is a beautiful thing
streams that's what we said men can
bounce around from woman a woman but if
I do it I'm a bad person that's not fair
for the first time actually allowed
myself to feel something there's nothing
more important in life than going after
what you love you're not going to be
able to fit into your dress all power is
count